قال حكم لوغانستان
ان القوات مشاه البحريه الاوكرانيه قصفت
مستودعه وقود للقوات الروسيه في قريه
ديبروفا في المقاطعه قايضاي النشره صور
قلاينها للمستودع الروسي بعد قصه مضيفا ان
الاستهدافه كان دقيقا وتسبب في تدمير
مخزون القوات الروسيه من الوقود وموده
تشحيم في المستودع بالكامل
الى ذلك قال موسى
ان الكريم
وانوارد القوات الروسيه قريبه من الحد
الادنى ومن هنا جاءت طلبات المفاوضات
في تغريده على تويتر
عن طريقه لمواصلات الحرب والحصول على
صواريخ وطائرات من دون طيار واصلاح نقص
الصواريخ واعتبر بدليات كان هذا هو الوقت
المثالي لمضاعفه المساعده لاوكرانيا
المتابعه ينضم الي من دونيس مراسله
الجزيره امين نادرغامي كما ينضم الي من
منطقه كوستن كنيفكا مراسل الجزيره عامر لا
في مرحبا بكما ابدا معك
امين والتفاصيل الميدانيه التي تذكرها
القوات الروسيه وتنفيها وتنفيها القوات
الاوكرانيه والعكس ايضا
محمد القائم باعمال رئيس
روسيا دينيس قال قبل قليل وفي تعليقه على
ما اعلنته قوته امس عن اكملها السيطره بسط
السيطره على كامل منطقه محيط مطار دونيتك
الدوليه قال بان هذه العمليه ستمكن قوته
من بدء تقدم جديد في عده محاور وهنا يقصد
بوشيل طبعا محاور كفيديو نووي وايضا
ومدينه افديفكا باعتبار ان تلك المناطق
تعد
تحصينات وخطوط دفاع متقدمه للجيش
الاوكراني في محيط في مدينتي
لها القوات المواليه لروسيا هنا في دنيا
طبعا اهميه قصوى باعتبار انها مناطق
يتهمون القوات الاوكرانيه دوما بانها تقصف
المناطق السكنيه انطلاقا من تلك المحاور
طبعا تحدث ايضا عن الاشتباكات والمعارك
التي وصفها بالقويه التي تدور الان في
بلده بابلو افكا قربى اوبلدارجه وقال بان
هدف هذه العمليه هو طبعا السيطره على
مدينه اوغليدار كما قال وبالتالي ابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه عن محيطي مدينه دمياط
اليوم سلطات هنا تحدثت عن جرح مدني واحد
على الاقل في قصف الاوكراني تعرض له حي
اكيد سكي وهو طبعا
هو احد الاحياء القريبه من خطا تماسي
اضافه الى تعرض مدن كيف وجورلاكا وياسين
القريبه ايضا من دونيسك لقصف اوكراني بحسب
السلطات المحليه في خير صوم تبدو الاوضاع
هناك ايضا نحو المزيد من التوتر السلطات
المواليه لروسيا هناك اليوم تحدثت عن
اجلاء 80,000 شخص لاسباب امنيه واسطه
حديثا من قبل همم همم صحفيين روس يتواجدون
هناك همم اعلنوا عن ان القوات الروسيه
بدات بتدمير بعض الجسور التي تربط
الضيفتين اليمنى واليسرى للنهر نيبرو في
مقاطعه اخر سون والقوات الموليه لروسيا
هناك تحدثت صباح اليوم محمد عن صد هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه على اكثر من محور واكدت
بان الوضع على طول خطا التماس ما زال على
ما هو عليه اي كل همم يعني جهه وكل طرف ما
زال همم يتمركز في مواقع
شمالا هناك معارك ايضا محتدمه في محيط
مدينه
تحاول همم اطفاء مزيد من وطبعا تنفيذ مزيد
من الضغط على القوات الاوكرانيه في نتلك
المدينه بالهجوم عبر عده محاور منها محور
جنوب هذه المدينه وايضا محور الشرق همم
عبر الطريق الذي ياتي من سوليدار وايضا
عبر الاحياء الشماليه في تلك المنطقه عد
ذلك باقي خطوط التماس وخطوط المواجهه
الرئيسيه في اقليم بن باز ما زالت يعني
دون تغييرات كبيره خلال ال 24 ساعه
باستثناء القصف المتبادله الذي لا يتوقف
بين الجانبين خاصه هنا قرب مدينه دمياط
عامر مثل ما ذكرت لي سؤال او في سؤالي
لامين تمت روايه وروايه مضاده وهذا امر
طبيعي جدا في حالاتها الحرب ما الذي تقوله
الروايه الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بالتطورات
على الارض خاصه انه يتعلق بدنيتك ولو جنس
نعم محمد نحن خرجنا قبل قليل من مدينه
محمود الان في كوستاريو قسطنطينيهكا هي
تقريبا تبعد نحو 20 كيلو متر هذا المكان
حيث ينقذ الان عن محمود لكن على الرغم من
ذلك ما زالت اصوات القذائف واصوات تبادل
القصف يصلنا حتى هنا بعيدا عن مدينه بخمود
هناك اصوات القصف لا تكاد تتوقف في
المدينه وواضح ان هناك معارك شرسه ما زالت
مستمره تحدثنا مع العسكريين هناك
الاوكرانيين تحدث لنا عن انهم في اليومين
الاخيرين امس واليوم حققوا تقدم جيد من
ناحيه الدفاع عن المدينه بمعنى انهم
الحقوا الكثير من الخسائر في صفوف القوات
المهاجمه طبعا تعلم قوات الروسيه التي
تقود بالعمليات هناك هي قوات شركه فاجنر
يقولون بانهم وجهه اليها يعني ضربات موجعه
خلال اليومين الماضيين وبالتالي هذا اثر
على قدرتهم على التقدم واثر على تثبيت
مواقع الدفاع الذي القوات الاوكرانيه لكن
الوضع على الارض الوضع المدنيين في
المدينه الوضع الانساني في المدينه يبقى
سيئا جدا وهم ايضا يعترفون بان حتى الوضع
الميداني ما زال صعب جدا لان هناك محاوله
او تصميم علامات ضمن القوات الروسيه لدخول
المدينه لكن الوضع الانساني كما ذكرت صعب
الخدمات الاساسيه كلها متوقفه داخل
المدينه اعداد قليله من الناس ما زالوا
يرفضون الخروج منها وبالتالي يصعب جدا
الحصول على الغذاء والدواء لا يوجد كهرباء
ولا ماء ولا غاز وبالتالي الوضع صعب هناك
في المدينه طبعا تبقى محمد هي- الاسخن
الجبهه الاسخن في كامل مقاطع لكن هذا يعني
انها المكان الوحيد وفقا لقياده الاركان
تحدثت في بيانها اليوم عن تمكن القوات
الاوكرانيه من صد اثنتا 10 محاوله روسيه
للتقدم على طول خطوط المواجهه وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن مساحه طويله وعدد كبير من
خطوط المواجهه ايضا نتحدث عن قصف ينال
ويطال العديد من المدن داخل مقاطعه دونيس
في الجانب الاوكراني وفقا لحاكم دونيس
الاوكراني قال بان هناك ثلاثه من القتل
المدنيين جراء هذا القصف الذي استهدف
العديد من القرى والبلدات احدى القى احد
القتلى هنا في هذه المدينه في احدى ضواحي
مدينه كوستنتين يبقى بعد سقوط قذيفه على
منزله ايضا هناك حديث عن ثمانيه جرحه جره
هذا القصف المكان الاخر طبعا واللي لا بد
من الحديث عنه المقاطعه الثانيه الجناح
الاخر
لاقليم بن باز يعني هنا لوغاز اليوم
حاكم حاكم همم لوكان لوكراني تحدث تحديدا
عن بلده همم بالقرفه هذه البلده التي قال
بانها تقصف بشكل يومي من جانب القوات
الروسيه ويقول بانه لم يعد فيها بيت لم
يتم تدميره ولكن على الرغم من ذلك ما زالت
قوات الاوكرانيه فيها تمنع وتصد الهجمات
المتتاليه من خلال القوات الروسيه
كنت معنا من كوستانت نيف كا شكرا جزيلا
كما اشكرك امين نادر هاني مراسل للجزيره
كنت معنا من تونس